let's go next to the six one four area
code six one four what's on your mind
today
yeah that's you okay
yes um I was just wondering uh I'm from
Australia so I was wondering what do you
do you think it would take for the
Americans to adopt something closer to
the Australian gun laws veteran yes
really and what what was the word d-las
oh it would take a monumental shift in
attitudes towards firearms it would take
complete appending of American gun
culture it would yeah I don't you know I
I tend to be on the issue of guns I
actually think that the path forward is
a more incremental approach sort of
reminiscent of Ted Kennedy and I know
that sounds boring but if anybody's
waiting around for some kind of massive
gun grabbing gun ban and and
confiscation of weapons or it's just not
going to happen and I think that the
best path forward is every single
election that there is at the local
state and federal level when presented
with candidates you go with the one who
is most going to focus on the issue of
firearms on gun safety rather than gun
fetishism and permissiveness and over
time you make a change and I know that a
lot of people will disagree with me
they'll say no no no no you've got this
is such an acute and pressing issue you
might have to burn it all down and
really make a drastic change I just have
a hard time believing that it's going to
happen given the fact that we do have a
Second Amendment that we do have really
strong pro-gun voices in the country
even shooting after shooting after
shooting of little kids in schools has
not gotten us to any notable changes on
that so I I don't know of any
circumstances under which we would get
in any semi direct way to Australian gun
laws here I just don't see it so you
don't think an event like we had in Port
Arthur where that changed everything
eventually overnight could happen in in
the state at the moment listen
there could be an event I that has not
happened which I could dream up and hope
that that would create seismic shifts
immediately in gun policy and attitudes
in the United States we've had horrible
shooting after horrible shooting and
still you hear people making excuses
from the gun fetishes side so I'm I'm
not super optimistic that any one event
would get people to change their minds
on guns okay thank you David all right
appreciate it thank you very much for
the call I wish that you know the
reality was more optimistic I just don't
I just don't see it if you were gonna
have one of those watershed moments yeah
I would have already happened
I am a B I agree or or even the the
consecutive events we've had recently